so cuppa tea good enough
seriously look at Selena Gomez now well
on New Year's Eve
the singers soaking up the Sun on a
yacht in Hawaii looking happy and fit in
an olive green bikini Selena's been
travelling with some of her BFFs move
also posted pics from the Aloha State I
love what I'm doing right now it's
enjoying my life and I'm getting to do
things that I'm passionate about with
the people that I love so Selena was
clearly feeling reflective during the
New Year's trip posting tons of pigs and
videos from the past year we also got
this pic of her with Taylor Swift's cats
Benjamin Button and these pics from
September 30th
aka Justin Bieber's wedding date and
yeah looks like she was having a blast
with her friends I like to come at
things with my best that's all I know
how to do life is about to get busy for
Selena she's dropping her new album rare
on January 10th
[Music]
last summer a source told ET celles new
music would be extremely personal and
she's already proven that like it was
easy more than anything I'm just I think
I feel a sense of relief you know it's
been four years since I've been working
on this album and it's actually perfect
timing because I was gonna release it
two years ago and none of the the words
that I'm speaking would have existed so
taking a moment to actually feeling the
feelings that I've gone through it's
been over four years since Selena
released an album and it's safe to say
she seems happy looks happy and her fans
are ready I'm just nervous about it
honestly because I feel like the next
few choices that I'm gonna make are very
crucial so I'm trying to be really
really diligent and just patient
[Music]